the Joe Rogan experience hey what
happened would we know about the Kanye
situation we're just gonna talk about
mental health I was kind of excited
about that I you know if he wants to he
can do it I'm not yeah he's he's a he's
a something he is a brilliant artist but
oftentimes a brilliant artist it's not
it's not the best format for them to
just talk like sometimes it's better for
them to express themselves through their
work maybe no although I found you know
I spent two days with them and I found
that when he's in a relaxed frame mm-hmm
his flow state is just it's beautiful
well I enjoyed talking to him I talked
to him on the phone I really enjoyed our
conversation we had a nice conversation
he said I think he's a very good do it's
very sensitive human yeah very cool guy
but this is not a relaxed environment
you know this right here everybody knows
how many people are listening it's just
if [ __ ] people's head really because the
illusion that I have is it's just you
and me talking and then I come out of
here and people like what do you say
well you and I are friends
so that illusion is more maintained when
you don't know me and you come in and I
mean I would have to be friends with
that's one of the things he wanted me to
come to his church you know he's got
these running a cult essentially
everybody's wearing white they're all
dance and doing religious stuff I do
that yeah so you're busy yes your family
studies are fairly well I run into I
just I get it I think it's beautiful you
know but I'm not he and I were walking
down the road and you know there was
this crippled alert that the critic from
Long Beach said you know Kanye better
stay in Calabasas it was a little bit of
a tense situation or so we're walking
along the road and like people were
hanging out of the windows of their car
you like Kanye and I think was just like
posit you know like why make contact but
it was very disconcerting and this guy
was preternatural II call you know he
was just like mm-hmm I was nervous how
long ago this this was you remember when
II went on TMZ well the the we talk in a
year or less the
I think it's probably a year ago it's
probably medicated not anymore
was that right yeah yeah he talked
openly about the fact that last six
months or so he's been off of his
medication and he whatever they had him
on was [ __ ] with him creatively well
you remember Oliver Sacks had this
chapter and the man who mistook his wife
for a hat about a drummer with
Tourette's syndrome no and then he just
took a drug to control the Tourette's
syndrome and the guy's drumming became
kind of monotonous very regular but like
not creative yeah you look the what that
guy's got inside of him he's so prolific
I mean you listen to his music it's so
interesting and eclectic and prolific
and he just constantly churning out more
great [ __ ] he doesn't have any flops I
mean his music is pretty [ __ ] amazing
and he's just that's his [ __ ] man he
knows how to just get in there and
create and he's got this whirlwind going
on in his mind he's fearless yeah he's
got he is explore and going into the
details but one of the things that
really impressed me was he would go to
places that I'm too scared to go to in
my own mind and well just you know
thinking about your inadequacies and
externalizing them and your
vulnerabilities and knowing you know
what is going to emasculate you and his
point is like I'm so comfortable with
myself that I'm gonna mine that as a
source of art because I bet it's in
everyone and you know by exploring these
contradictions and these false fronts
and you know he's he's got a level of
internal access I I'm actually quite
interested in the mental health aspect
of this which is there's so much so much
mental unhealth as we as we term it
mm-hmm that I don't think it's all
mental and health I do think that
there's something about the artistic
process that seems to be very informed
by states that we call in health yeah
well we require people to stay inside
these rigid boundaries and these rigid
boundaries they're they're great if you
want to show up at a job and work 9:00
to 5:00 and don't use certain noises
with your mouth because it makes people
upset you know but that's not for the
creative process if you look at true
outliers if you want to discuss true
outliers like people that are really
capable of producing extraordinary art
or architecture or works you know
different interesting things that are
part of the creative process those
people are all unwell every single one
of them I mean in terms of like if you
made them do what a normal person has to
do every day I think normal life is
unwell in terms of this this requirement
of showing up five minutes early working
all day long getting off maybe bringing
some of your work home getting some
sleep getting up in the morning and
doing it all over again all while
raising a family and trying to enjoy
your time your limited finite time on
this planet well this is why I said I've
left after you left is that it's not
healthy here
[Applause]